we are with maxim vashir lagrav maxim
quite a solid start plus one after uh
three rounds how do you feel
yeah i
obviously didn't play
am i doing my plots for today because
i started with two blogs uh three very
tough opponents
so i knew i should expect a tough tough
day first two games were kind of
difficult speaking of that you started
with the qga then you switched to your
uh groomfield how did you make that
decision
no i planned to play um
to play grenfell but against knight f i
decided to go for qga avoid the
anti-grunfeld in that one yes and you
avoid so many lines
in the qga when white goes knight after
that i thought it was worth it
absolutely and then in the last round
you played against um
mahmed yarov how did you approach this
game
i mean i knew that uh
this um
open spanish could happen so i decided
to play solid because i had two
two long games
um
but then shaq played queen d7 i thought
you would go castle and
this is more solid for black
um and i don't know i felt like i had
the advantage but then i
i waited a bit
too long like it did feel like yeah from
this position i i felt like i was yeah
bishop b1 i mean this
is so
so passive yeah king h2 of course
um
bishop b1 is slow and maybe queen d3
create some more
problems on this okay when discrete g6 i
didn't actually want queen e3 g7 because
very often i want uh knight h2 f5 so
so i actually didn't want him to to play
g6
but bishop b1 here was a bit slow and
then
when did you feel like you were taking
over or when you feel like he made the
last mistake yeah so later on because my
position was actually not that great i
thought a4 was uh
quite a mistake actually
so then i took because he cannot really
take any piece because of bishop b5 so
after
if he takes on a2 bishop to b5 for
instance yeah yeah
um
and here yeah
a5 i also was a
good move but
at the same time
i wasn't completely sure because then my
point goes to a6 hispan goes to b3 and
uh it's a race yeah like knight
a6 queen to e4 seems to be the best move
yeah
it is better for me but i thought bishop
if i was safer
and then uh
then we actually went more or less by
force yeah i wanted to go e6 yeah
and instead of
here
yes
bishop take c4
is that what you calculated
yeah bishop take c4 i thought bishop f3
angle
so
yeah on d7
so hook takes d4
there was some crazy line wait wait
yes here um i think rook c4 was
a bit
crazy
like queen b5
rook d7 rook d7
rook c8
king h7 if i with the pawn it should be
a draw so queen f5 g6 queen f6 queen f1
oh that's beautiful
that's beautiful king h2 g2 yeah xf1
rook to d1 oh that's a shot that's nasty
so i was calculating all this because i
thought afterwards if i would be
pressing but then i had to settle for d7
which i assume was a draw
because we get by force to this position
at least i'm not running any danger but
i assumed it would be a draw somewhere
and
but then i yeah g5 felt very wrong
i must say
g5 felt like a
like i thought i've talked in g6 for
instance
uh i mean
perhaps i i mean i was going to try like
play rockefeller
before but i assume i never can manage
to create something and then
when suddenly i get my rook to f3 and
i'm winning the f7 pawn by force
i mean might still be a draw but
it looks already very scary yeah queen
to d1 is maybe yeah i thought g5 just
helped me tremendously because there's
never perpetual
and we all congratulations a good start
for you good luck tomorrow thank you
christian
thank you kristen and uh indeed uh nice
a nice day for mvl here